.
THANK YOU.
>> Trace: HOUSE REPUBLICANS ARE
HOLDING PUBLIC HEARINGS THIS
AFTERNOON ORIGINS OF COVID
WHETHER IT LEAKED FROM A LAB IN
WUHAN, CHINA.
THEY WANT NANCY PELOSI TO
CONDUCT HEARINGS.
SO FAR SHE HAS REFUSED.
FORMER STATE DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATOR DAVID ASHER WILL
TESTIFY TODAY AND JOINS US NOW.
DR. ASHER, GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON.
I WANT TO PUT ON THE SCREEN YOU
WILL TESTIFY AND ADMIRAL
GIROIR, DR. RICHARD MUELLER AND
DR. QUAY.
IN THIS FORUM WITH LAWMAKERS
WHAT DO YOU WANT THE DIRECTION
OF THIS FORUM TO BE?
>> I REALLY WANT TO FOCUS ON
THE DESIGNS AND CAPABILITIES
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
DEVELOPMENT DEVELOPED AROUND
SYNTHETIC BIOLOGY IN THE FUTURE
WARFARE.
I'M NOT IT WAS RELEASED AS AN
ATTACK VECTOR USING BIOLOGY BUT
THEY WERE DEVELOPING IT
SECRETLY AT THE WUHAN INSTITUTE
OF VIROLOGY AND APPARENTLY GOT
LOOSE THROUGH AN ACCIDENT THAT
HAS HAD -- WE HAVE TO HOLD THE
CHINESE ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT'S THE FOCUS.
NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE.
EVERYBODY SHOULD AGREE WITH
THIS.
>> Trace: WE HEAR WE HAVE TO
HOLD CHINA -- SANCTIONS AND
VISA RESTRICTIONS AND
RELOCATING THE OLYMPICS.
IS THIS ENOUGH IN YOUR
ESTIMATION TO COMPEL THE
CHINESE TO COOPERATE?
>> PROBABLY NOT ENOUGH.
WE MAY NEVER BE ABLE TO COMPEL
THEM TO COOPERATE.
WE MAY BE ABLE TO COERCE THEM.
DIFFERENT THAN BEING A NICE
DIPLOMAT LIKE I WAS TRAINED TO
BE.
WE CAN BE A LOT MORE COERCIVE.
SANCTIONS CAN BE MORE DRACONIAN
IN NATURE IF THEY DON'T COMPLY
WITH EVIDENCE.
WE COULD UNLEASH THE GREAT
AMERICAN AMBULANCE LAWYERS WHO
COULD MAKE THE CIVIL LITIGATION
CLAIMS AGAINST THE CHINESE ON
BEHALF OF ALL THESE VICTIMS.
WE HAVE LOST 600,000 PEOPLE.
RUINED THE LIVES OF MILLIONS
AND WE'VE SET BACK OUR ECONOMY
NEARLY 20% OF GDP.
THIS IS THE WORST THING SINCE
THE GREAT DEPRESSION AND SOME
WAYS COMBINED ECONOMICALLY.
>> Trace: THERE HAS BEEN A LOT
OF TALK ABOUT CONSEQUENCES.
SO FAR WE'VE SEEN CHINA
EXPERIENCE FEW CONSEQUENCES.
STEVE SCALISE SAID NEVER FORGET
WHAT HAPPENED WHEN REPUBLICANS
RIGHTLY SAID COVID LIKELY CAME
FROM THE WUHAN LAB.
MEDIA CALLED US CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS.
THE DEM COMMITTEE REFUSES TO
HOLD A COMMITTEE ON IT.
TIME FOR ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE WORD ACCOUNTABILITY.
HE IS RIGHT IN ONE CAPACITY.
WE DID LOSE A GREAT DEAL OF
TIME BECAUSE OF THOSE DELAYS.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO BLAME THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ON THIS ONE.
WE'VE HAD EXCELLENT MEETINGS SO
FAR IN WASHINGTON WITH
DEMOCRATIC STAFFERS AND MEMBERS
AT LEAST BY REMOTE.
I JUST THINK THEY DON'T WANT TO
BE IN THE SAME ROOM WITH
REPUBLICANS ON THIS THING AND
MAYBE VICE VERSA.
I CAN'T FIX THE PARTISANSHIP IN
THIS TOWN BUT WE CAN FIX WHAT
THE COMMUNIST CHINESE DID TO
TRY TO UNDERMINE OUR COUNTRY
AND THE WORLD SYSTEM WITH COVID
EVEN IF THEY DIDN'T DO IT
DELIBERATELY THEY KNEW IT WOULD
SPREAD AND THEY LET IT SPREAD
AND IT COST US MILLIONS OF
LIVES AND WE HAVE TO BRING
THESE PEOPLE OVER COMMUNIST
CHINA.
>> Trace: WHAT ABOUT THE MEDIA
AND BIG TECH THAT CENSORED THE
STORY SAYING IT WAS NOTHING BUT
A CONSPIRACY?
>> THEY WERE WRONG FROM THE
BEGINNING AND THEY WILL BE
PROVEN WRONG AND WRONG AND
WRONGER IF THERE IS SUCH A
PHRASE.
THE SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE THAT
DR. QUAY AND DR. MUELLER ARE
PRESENTING ARE REALLY
UNDISPUTED FACTS.
THE QUESTION IS HOW DID THEY
GET THERE AND I'LL LET THEM
TALK ON YOUR SHOW SOME OTHER
TIME.
IT IS VERY POWERFUL DATA
ANALYSIS.
THE SEQUENCE ITSELF TELLS YOU
SOMETHING DESPITE WHAT ALL THE
SCIENTISTS HAVE SAID AND I'VE
HEARD IT FROM MANY FAMOUS
SCIENTISTS.
NONE WANT TO GO ON THE RECORD
BECAUSE THEY ARE AFRAID THE
CHINESE WILL CUT THEM OFF FROM
FUNDING AND SO WILL N.I.H.
>> WE'L